vamos a ver si podemos encontrar la
integral definida desde 11 pm dios hasta
6 pib de 9 veces el seno de x de x lo
primero que vamos a hacer es ver si
podemos encontrar la anti derivada de 9
veces el seno de x y para eso podemos
usar algunas de las propiedades de
integración para simplificar un poco
esto entonces esto me quedara como 9
veces la integral definida desde 11 p
medios hasta 6 pib de el seno de x de x
ahora cuál es la anti derivada del seno
de x bueno sabemos por acá lo voy a
poner que la derivada del coseno de x es
igual al menos seno de x entonces
podemos construir esta integral de
alguna forma para que la parte de
adentro sea menos seno de x que pasa se
multiplicó lo de adentro por menos uno
bueno no puedo hacerlo así simplemente
tengo que multiplicar dos veces x menos
1 para no cambiar el valor de la
integral pero si pongo menos 9 veces la
integral del menú seno de x
y entonces sigo teniendo nueve veces de
x ya que los signos se cancelarían pero
lo hice esta manera porque ahora menos
seno de x coinciden con la derivada de
coseno de x y ahora tengo que esto va a
ser igual a menos 9 que multiplica y lo
voy a poner con corchetes a la anti
derivada de menos
x que ya sabemos que es el coste no de x
déjame no tardó el coseno de x ya este
coseno de x lo vamos a evaluar en los
límites de integración es decir en 6 pin
y en 11 p medios y entonces esto va a
ser igual a menos 9 que multiplican voy
a abrir un corchete muy grande y
multiplicar al coseno de 6 p - el coseno
de 11 primeros el coseno de 6 pin - el
coseno de 11 p medios
y cuál es el coste no de 6 pies bueno el
coste no de cualquier múltiplo de 2 pib
es 1 y puedes ver el coste de 6 pib como
si fuéramos alrededor del círculo
unitario 3 veces entonces esto es lo
mismo que el coseno de 2 espn o es lo
mismo que el coste no de 0 que es igual
a 1 y si esto no te es familiar te
encargo que veas los vídeos sobre los
valores que toma el coche no en el
círculo unitario
ahora bien cuánto es el coseno de 11
prime dios bueno pues estamos múltiplos
de 2 para obtener un valor que
entendamos mejor y que sea más manejable
así que déjame escribirlo por aquí y
vamos a trabajar con coseno de 11 mil
medios y bueno voy a decir que esto va a
ser igual y ahora el coseno de 11 medios
es lo mismo que y veamos esto es lo
mismo que cinco enteros un medio de pib
no es así así que qué te parece si le
restamos 4 pin
bueno 4 pies lo mismo que 8 primeros
entonces me va a quedar como el coseno
de 11 y medios menos 8 y medios una vez
más estoy restando es múltiplo de 2 pib
para que no cambien el valor del coseno
y entonces esto es igual al coseno de
tres primeros y ahora cuánto vale esto
bueno pues si imaginamos el círculo
unitario de hecho déjame dibujarlo por
aquí vamos a dibujar por aquí un círculo
unitario estos van a ser mis ejes y por
aquí voy a dibujar un círculo mi círculo
unitario y por aquí vamos a tener al
cero y si aquí tenemos el cero luego
aquí arriba tenemos a pi medios después
por aquí tenemos a pi y luego por acá
vamos a tener a tres primeros así que
estamos en este punto en el círculo
unitario y recuerda el coche no es la
coordenada x entonces este coche lo que
buscamos va a ser simplemente cero
tanto nos queda dentro del corchete 10
es todo lo que tenemos entre los
corchetes lo cual es igual a 1 y menos 9
por 1 es igual a menos 9 así que déjenme
atraparlo este es el resultado de
evaluar esta integral